you know what they say nothing sexier
than a girl's to lips push yourselves ha
ha ha ha there's some leg ha ha ha look
at this
do I look like Urban Outfitters calm
apartment section o you shi'a gooses
entered the room are you coming up there
to hang out here no bigot dad she just
went for a walk ha ha yeah you did read
some sass between those lines cuz you
you are out of breath she wears the
pants in this relationship
hey ok bye hello welcome to friary fried
area if you did not know is a look back
at my week in vlog form on February 2nd
I released my second book Grace and
style and I went on a book tour all
across the United States do signings and
meet a lot of you guys and here's a look
back at the last week of book tour hey
guys we're backstage back bookstore not
staged book store book store in
Naperville yeah we basically came here
from the airport because our flight was
5 hours delayed they are limit on how
long we could keep you on the airplane
with the door closed because of that and
from the time of our original push back
which was 917 so look at all these fun
toiletries there's many odors literally
coded by self a dry shampoo feelin good
feelin solid you'll see I'll discuss
backstage of a book so are ya gonna go
see all these beautiful neighbor Phil
Pearman see me in welcoming the one and
only back Anderson right now Hey
are happy people where dare day hello
good morning from Chicago oh man
yesterday I'm so popular yesterday was
an epic adventure to get to Chicago and
now tis the morning and oh my god
to the German girl that I met last night
it gave me these candies thank you and
skew I've eaten like half of these
already because they're so good they're
like hazelnut chocolate oh my god
someone give me potpourri
so necessary and these adorable Anstead
shirts and for my phone spirit animal
laugh and and eminem cuz yeah this is me
as close as I get to owning a sex toy
thank you guys for all of that today we
are headed to Milwaukee I feel like the
Midwest because everyone's super I'm so
popular you guys and I also that's
probably happening because I have to go
I always run like if you know me just
expect me to be 10-15 minutes late I'm
so sorry
I'd like to say I'm working on it I
don't even know if I'm working on it oh
here's outfit of the day this shirts
from Topshop these jeans are from H&M
I've been wearing them like crazy and
they're awesome they're like
high-waisted super super soft jeans and
they're really cheap I think they might
have been like twenty or thirty dollars
so if you need new jeans go for
especially long-legged ladies hi girls
hi friends I can't find jeans that are
long enough H&M has really long jeans
let's go to some fun things day well if
I look done it looks like Matthew
McConaughey okay
you look so great hey parents looking
good now we're Minneapolis well I just
saved my hotel room and look what's here
oh my god this is so cool and sweet
thank you w hotel
what's in his box unboxing video 12
million views oh there's my thumbnail
boobs 8 million views okay so um first
of all yes I did buy myself a Packers
sweatshirt in the Milwaukee Airport also
okay so looking over here for some
reason I thought this was a mirror for I
don't even know I thought this was a
mirror and then I just realized that
this is a bathroom
oh cool bathroom let's look at the view
oh hello Minneapolis you look cool
virtual snowflakes my favorite kind of
snow is digital snow how are you okay
we're done haha there's light good
morning I'm running so late I should be
downstairs already but we're going to
the Minneapolis Mull of America which is
really extra appropriate because that is
written about in my book and to write
about in my book actually when on the
website was looking at floor plans of
them all to make sure that everything I
referenced was actually in reality close
to each other so we are going down there
I need to go now I thought I'd give you
Utd my outfit of the day for the signing
today I'm wearing black sweatpants
head-to-toe all one piece and some
Adidas sneakers is this fashion
hi friary we have made it officially to
Austin Texas the rest of the time in
Minneapolis went really really well
I went to Target and I got to see
Grayson style in target in real life
that's the first time I've seen the book
actually in a bookstore has been target
right now look what I found
Wow Grace's guide the first book was
never in target and so Grayson style
being in target now and target being a
place that I frequent because of like
maybe an unhealthy addiction but like
easily like marginalized because of it
being so widespread it feels really
great so do me a favor tweet at me at
grace Helbig hashtag Grayson style
photos of you at Target seeing the book
or buying the book or whatever it is
it's 20% off at Target pairing it proves
itself once again to feed possibly
unhealthy addiction but we all got it so
is it that bad crap probably wouldn't be
so bad if everyone had it we were in
Austin Texas now and I have a couple
hours before I need to be doing no
that's not true I should be doing things
right now I'm saying that I have a
couple hours but a couple of hours
before I go to the book signing tonight
here in Austin and so I'm doing what I
should be doing in Austin eating
jambalaya in bed hello ladies gentlemen
I just went to the gym I just got the
general or did I just wake up from a
nightmare same thing I've got an hour
before I get picked up for the awesome
signing I want to show you this is Yost
ensiling before I'm a terrific kid Hey
look this t-shirt is actually referenced
somewhere in the book written style to
me a picture of the page if you can find
it creative marketing sorry yeah here's
after it looks kind of a mess and that's
because I'm so late let's go
they're coming at sustainers slow
internet friends um we are in Seattle
right now this green blue tint that you
see is just natural Seattle this
beautiful bed um but really look at this
beautiful room suite that they put me
and it's called the author suite um duh
actual [ __ ] look it's got wine which uh
not drinking right now fruit and then
it's got a fireplace which I mean to me
fireplaces are like it's the thought
that counts is at lord knows I I'm not
gonna why would i light a fire the only
fires I lighter accidental which is all
these books ballerina
office love dance and then look at a
pathetic lady lamp and we turn you on
lady lamp that's what he said or she
said or they said I don't know it's
modern times up the buttons down here
can never find the right spot lots of
people it happens to that tilda swinton
mara we'll be doing a live signing which
I'm really excited about we're basically
everyone that comes to a book signing by
its book and I signed it and we hang out
and take photos so for all of you that I
didn't do book signings in towns and
cities of or countries of we're doing a
live signing which will already happened
by the time you see this video but the
idea behind it is that you can buy a
book and then will virtually digitally
hang out I'm going to do a live stream
signing all the books and talking to you
guys and possibly calling some of you
calling using a phone what your is this
$19.99 so many cabinets you guys so many
places to hide my feelings
we're in New York Times bestseller ah it
makes me really happy I just got a phone
call from my agency managers saying that
we made the New York Times bestseller
list for bestsellers advice how to a
miscellaneous and that's awesome and
this means a lot to me just if you will
not mind my sincerity for one second you
hate sincerity just click ahead this is
really exciting and I know a lot of
YouTube books have been making the
seller lists and it might seem I'm not
like normal which is crazy to even say
that out loud but this is very cool
because this book racing-style was um oh
my god okay calm down for a second so
that's how I put all the feelings back
inside this was really special because
it was a really personal book
I feel like whoa I hope I put a bunch of
fart noises over this so thank you guys
for that the cool cool thing about this
is that this time of year host New
Year's resolutions everyone wants to buy
advice books about healthy living and
eating well and losing weight and
cleaning up your house properly I mean
grace and style is meant to be a book
about celebrating the silliness of all
of that struggle it's really really cool
to be on this list with all of these
diet plans and to write a book talking
about my own eating disorder how weird
and ironic is all that life is stupid
and now fun to be announcing this while
wearing a Green Bay Packers sweatshirt
and then the morning after the Seattle
signing I got on a flight came back to
LA went into James Corden's show
and then the designing at the grow and
it was such a great signing and a really
wonderful way to end my USA grace and
style book tour and now I'm back in LA
and I've just been domestic ass doing
things like walking tired tired out of
breath dogs and tomorrow
oh you for did that Maura Natalie for
the UK part of the tour really excited
for all of you that are in the UK I'm
coming to a bunch of places they were
police Manchester others Waterstone what
Bluewater cuddles cuddles stove we're
sure sure paliku lots lane I don't know
I don't know where I'm going
but you can know if you go to great
style book.com slash tour all over the
places that I will be are there and all
the links to register to come to the
signings are there cuz you have to
register and I would love to see you
guys at signing so please register and
hang out with me thank you to everyone
in the u.s. that was able to come to the
signings it's been so lovely meeting all
of you guys and I'm really excited to
see UK ice you cares you cares that's a
fun new way to say like are you okay you
cares no come also that's it I don't
know oh by the way yes she is wearing a
holiday sweater because she's a fishing
dog and doesn't scream no time